المنطاد الصيني لا يزال يشغل الولايات
المتحده والاستخبارات في البلاد تتحقق في
هويه العالم الذي او العالم الذي طور هذا
المنطاد والرجل المثير للجدل هو الباحث
الصيني المرموق في جامعه بيهنج
الذي يرجح ان يكون واحدا من المعقول
التقنيه والابتكار في البلد الاسيوي
وللمصادفه فقد فرضت واشنطن عقوبات على
شركات صينيه في العاشر من فبراير جاري اي
في اليوم الذي يصادف عيد الميلاد السادس
والستين لهذا العالم الصيني ولم تشهر
السلطات الامريكيه بالاسم الى العالم
الصيني ولكنها اوضحت انها فرضت العقوبات
على الشركات بسبب دورها في امداد الجيش
الصيني بمعدات واليات للتجسس والاستطلاع
من جانب اخر المنطاد الصيني فتح شهيه
الامريكيين على السخريه من اخبار الاجسام
الغريبه والمجهوله التي ظهرت في بحيره
ميشيغان الامريكيه واخلاق المجال الجوي
فيها لاسباب تتصل بالدفاع القومي ابرز
التعليقات جاءت من الملياردير الامريكي
الى ماسك حيث علق ساخرا بالقول لا تقلقوا
بعض من اصدقاء الفضائيين سيزورون الارض
[موسيقى]